l'aéroport de nairobi dimanche 1er
octobre il est 5 heures du matin le
kenya est un pays dangereux selon
washington où le terrorisme peut frapper
à tout moment j'ai la double nationalité
française et américaine
aujourd'hui j'utiliserai mon passeport
américain je veux vivre dans la peau
d'un de mes compatriotes
sur le site internet de l'administration
américaine on peut lire ces mots
enlèvement attaque suicide attentats à
en croire ce document le pays est une
des plaques tournantes d'al qaïda en
afrique
dès mon arrivée à nairobi je prends la
route de l'ambassade des états unis elle
est située dans les quartiers les plus
chics de la capitale kényane je sais
qu'aujourd'hui une proche de collines
powell le ministre des affaires
étrangères a rendez vous avec les
expatriés
elle est là pour leur parler de la
menace terroriste
sur le chemin impossible de rater les
symboles de la puissance économique des
états unis mais un peu plus loin un
nouveau symbole surgit
mecca cola un substitut de la célèbre
boisson américaine le soda fait un
carton auprès des musulmans dans le pays
comme avec mon chauffeur il s'appelle
rajab mohamed
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre il
se sent menacé
c'est difficile d'être musulman kenya
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus
pratiquer librement notre religion et ça
c'est à cause de la politique américaine
vous savez au parlement ils sont en
train de voter les lois antiterroristes
qui nous interdirait de nous habiller en
bon musulman et même de porter notre
kéfir notre coiffe traditionnelle bc
calais on pense tous que cette loi est
mauvaise et que les états unis font
pression sur notre gouvernement pour la
faire adopter nous ne voulons pas d'une
telle ingérence
on approche bien d'autres ambassades la
radio ouï mais ne sort pas ta caméra ici
l'ambassade est très surveillée
ça te rend un peu nerveux de tricherie
radjavi oui bien sûr
tant que musulman avec mon kéfir je ne
me sens pas rassuré d'être ici ils
peuvent m'accuser datera terroriste
juste pour ça
des troupes d'élite de l'armée kenyane
boucle le périmètre impossible pour moi
de sortir la caméra
je vais tenter de rentrer dans
l'ambassade avec une caméra cachée elle
est dissimulée dans un sac à dos
[Musique]
le bâtiment est à 300 mètres de l'un
dans un second périmètre de sécurité
difficile d'y perpétrer un attentat
comme en 1998 il y a 6 ans l'ambassade
américaine se situé en plein centre
ville une voiture piégée avait fait plus
de 300 morts c'était la première attaque
d'al qaïda contre des intérêts
américains
ici les consignes sont strictes personne
ne passe sans raison précise sauf bien
sûr si l'on est américain
et je peux pas prendre de photos de
l'ambassade la non absolument pas c'est
pour des raisons de sécurité oui bien
sûr un d'accord vous savez dans cette
nouvelle ambassade la sécurité a été
renforcée rien à voir avec l'ancien
bâtiment en plus ça aide de ne plus être
au centre ville
[Musique]
effectivement à l'intérieur du sas de
sécurité un détecteur de métal est une
machine à rayons x
[Musique]
ma caméra sera tout de suite repéré
beauchemin
au guichet j'apprends que l'envoyée
spéciale de koh lanta wall a prévu une
autre réunion demain à mombasa pour la
communauté américaine qui habitent en
dehors de la capitale
je décide de me rendre
six heures de route et quelques 450
kilomètres plus tard me voici à mombasa
c'est la perle de l'océan indien le
coeur de la communauté musulmane au
kenya ici le terrorisme a déjà frappé
deux fois
2002 une voiture piégée explose contre
l'hôtel paradis et une attaque à la
roquette rate de peu un avion de ligne
israélien depuis les touristes
américains ont disparu
mon chauffeur à mombasa n'est pas
musulman il s'appelle christiaen pour
lui comme pour tout le monde ici depuis
trois ans la vie n'est plus la même
que pense-t-on des américains ici à mon
besoin
il savait les américains étaient une
vraie mine d'or pour l'économie ici
mais de plus le terrorisme a frappé on
n'en voit plus beaucoup
l'économie en souffre beaucoup
c'est introduire pour tout le monde au
nord de la ville le bord de mer et ses
hôtels de luxe c'est dans l'un d'entre
eux va se tenir la réunion barrières de
protection contrôle d'identité à
l'entrée et surtout inspection du
châssis à l'aide d'un miroir des mesures
de sécurité censées rassurer les
touristes
la rencontre a lieu dans l'une des
salles de conférence de l'hôtel
je ressors ma caméra cachée
mais à ma grande surprise il n'y a aucun
dispositif particulier pour filtrer
l'entrée les deux gars de mela ce passé
sombre fouillé il ne me demande pas mes
papiers d'identité non plus
dans la salle une cinquantaine
d'américains la plupart sont
missionnaire ou humanitaires cela fait
plus d'un an qu'ils n'ont pas vu un
officiel américain à mombasa
je rencontre enfin mort a redit l'envoyé
spécial de collines powell
avant même de pouvoir lui parler un
expatrié l'interpellent
ils sont tous musulmans ici et tout le
monde nous déteste on y est
personnellement je n'ai jamais eu de
problèmes ni de menaces mais il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose pour
changer cette tendance cette haine
n'arrête pas de grandir ça en devient
ridicule
que l'on soit démocrate ou républicain
ça n'a même plus d'importance on nous en
est et à washington rien n'est fait
changer l'opinion publique du monde
envers notre pays la réunion commence
j'en suis encore à me demander comment
on a pu me laisser approcher un
diplomate américain sans fouiller mes
deux sacs c'est le chef de la sécurité
de l'ambassade qui prend la parole bien
sûr son identité doit rester
confidentielles le discours est
alarmiste le risque terroriste est
encore très présent n'oubliez pas que
nous vivons dans un monde très violent
l'actualité nous le rappelle chaque jour
les attentats anti américains sont
devenus monnaie courante enlèvements
assassinats et attentats ne sont que la
partie visible de l'iceberg les autres
choses je préfère ne pas les évoquer
devant lui sachez que pour moi il n'y a
aucun doute
el qaïda est encore au kenya et son
idéologie va continuer à pousser des
gens à prendre pour cible les intérêts
américains dans la région
retour à nairobi l'un des américains les
plus connus de la région acceptent de me
rencontrer
c'est le pdg de general motors le titan
de l'automobile américaine
qualiac buick chevrolet son usine de
nairobi fournit toute l'afrique de l'est
bilé est une cible idéale pour les
terroristes mais depuis le 11 septembre
il a transformé son usine en véritables
camps retranchés les caméras de sécurité
les gardes sont omniprésents
regarde là haut on vient de mettre une
nouvelle caméra
vous faites plus attention aujourd'hui
avec les personnes que vous embauchez
absolument il faut savoir que des
terroristes peuvent s'infiltrer ici en
tant qu'ouvrier tout ce qu'il leur
faudrait pour rentrer dans l'usiné ses
portes et un bleu de travail
heureusement notre dispositif de
sécurité très efficace et si moi je
venais travailler ici au kenya quelles
seraient vos conseils
c'est simple depuis deux ans on ne nous
regarde pas de la même façon en afrique
de l'est a il faut donc suivre quelques
règles de bon sens éviter tout
rassemblement entre américains et aussi
éviter de le crier sur tous les toits en
fait il faut vraiment faire profil bas
resté discret et simplement apprécier
les qualités de ce pays magnifique
il travaille chez general motors depuis
trente ans il tient à me montrer une des
choses les plus difficiles qu'il ait eu
à faire
regardez ici se trouvait avant notre
grande enseigne general motors elle
couvrait tout le haut du bâtiment
mais après le 11 septembre pour des
raisons de sécurité on nous a demandé de
faire profil bas et beaucoup d'autres
grandes entreprises américaines ont
suivi notre exemple
profil bas peut-être mais sécurité
maximum double grillage électrifié
patrouille de chiens projecteurs et
surtout une attention toute particulière
à la sécurité personnelle de bill
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 bill
est suivi par cette voiture escorte à
l'intérieur ses gardes du corps ne lâche
jamais même lorsqu'il part en week end
ou en safari
trois policiers dans la voiture de scort
et un an celle de bill ils sont reliés
entre eux par contact radio il ne laisse
jamais plus de dix mètres entre les deux
voitures
est ce que beaucoup d'américains sont
protégés comme ben ils n'ont pas tous
les américains bill est un pays perd
gagne 1
nous sommes des policiers des forces
spéciales nous avons été formés pour la
protection rapprochée et la lutte
antiterroriste
bill ne pense pas que ces mesures de
sécurité soit excessive vous craignez de
trop élevé
bien sûr l'enlèvement a toujours été un
véritable risque pour les américains à
l'étranger on me demande de changer mes
habitudes de ne pas prendre le même
chemin pour aller travailler et vous le
faites vous bien sûr je change aussi mes
heures d'arrivée départ
bienvenue à mousser et galeux beverly
hills de nairobi dans ce quartier tout
le monde vit sous haute surveillance
juste avant d'arriver chez bill son
chauffeur actionne une télécommande un
signal prévient les gardes de la maison
qui ouvre aussitôt les portes de cette
façon la voiture de bill n'est jamais
immobilisé
les gardes du corps restent en poste
même à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de la
propriété
que l'on soit l' usine ou chez lui bill
est obsédé par la sécurité
tient bien voir diego je vais te montrer
les systèmes de sécurité que j'ai fait
installer
bon d'abord on a mis en place une
palissade en acier et des barbelés tout
autour il ya aussi une caméra de
surveillance à l'entrée est de cette
façon si quelqu'un se présente à la
porte le soir j'appuie sur un des
boutons de la télécommande de ma télé et
je peux voir qui est là et ensuite je
dit aux gars de laisser entrer
j'en viens à me demander comment bill
fait pour vivre en état de siège mais je
ne suis pas au bout de mes surprises
bon et pour terminer dans beaucoup de
maisons du quartier nous avons ce que
l'on appelle une zone sécurisée
l'idée derrière ce concept c'est que
même si quelqu'un réussit à pénétrer
dans la maison tu le laisse faire ce
qu'il veut au rez de chaussée toi tu es
à laitages tu t'enfermes derrière ses
barreaux dans ta zone sécurisée
et vous fait ça tous les soirs
oui tous les soirs et si quelqu'un
rentrer par effraction
ça me donne le temps d'actionner les
alarmes depuis les pièces duo
la police arif deux minutes plus tard et
ses grilles me permettent de tenir
jusqu'à leur intervention
une forteresse imprenable m'assure bill
mais à quel prix
bill si je regarde par la fenêtre je
vois des grilles des barbelés des murs
en acier et j'ai vu ces choses avant
mais c'était dans des prisons tu sais on
s'y fait à la longue ça fait partie de
ma vie aujourd'hui c'est le prix de ma
sécurité ici c'est parfait pour
m'empêcher de sortir mais pour empêcher
les autres d'entrée c'est la grande
différence
bill n'est pas le seul américain à vivre
dans une résidence hautement sécurisée
dans le quartier de la nouvelle
ambassade des états unis radja obtient à
me montrer l'un des derniers projets
immobiliers en cours il est
exclusivement réservé aux américains
depuis ce parking nous aurons une vue
imprenable sur le lotissement on est où
ici radium on est au village markets est
le plus grand centre commercial généraux
et là on peut reconnaître les maisons
des américains en contrebas avec leurs
murs et leur barbelés
c'est de cette façon qu'ils vont vivre
maintenant kenya parce qu'ils ont peur
d'être la cible de ces attaques
terroristes
cela fait moins de deux minutes que raj
avait moi sommes sur le parking un garde
vient nous demander pourquoi nous
filmons
je suis un journaliste américain je suis
en train de faire un reportage êtes
américains
mes explications ne suffiront pas
son supérieur lui demande même par
talkie walkie que je présente mes
papiers
j'obtempère
décidément au kenya passeport américain
égale sésame
c'est bon c'est bon pas trop bon merci à
la prochaine on est content jobs c'est
un vrai joker ce passeport le garder
pour un musulman ce serait bien d'avoir
un passeport comme ça ben oui bien sûr
c'est en voudriez toi si j'avais un
passeport comme celui ci je serais
vraiment très content grâce à ce
passeport je pourrais voyager partout
sans problème allez visiter l'amérique
autant de fois que je veux avec mon
passeport kényan et un nom comme khadija
ben mohamed je ne peux même pas imaginer
qu'un jour je verrai l'amérique
rajab pris dans l'une des mosquées les
plus radicales de nairobi je lui demande
si je peux rencontrer son imam le sheikh
mohammed rajab accepte mais il me
conseille de me présenter comme
journaliste français
il a raison à mon accent l'imam me prend
pour un américain il ne m'autorise pas à
filmer finalement gelée mon passeport
français
lorsque je suis arrivé vous m'avez
demandé si j'étais un américain parce
que je parlais avec un accent oui votre
accent oui mon accent mais pourquoi
est-ce que c'était important
parce que lorsque vous m'avez dit que
vous étiez français j'ai trouvé ça très
suspect ce pic vous savez j'ai souvent
parlé avec des américains et je connais
leur accent et votre façon de parler tu
es bien comme la leur
moi j'ai justement rencontré beaucoup
d'américains au kenya et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont peur de
musulmans
écoutez moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose nous les musulmans nous sommes les
amis de tous les êtres humains et même
des américains
battent les ils n'en veulent pas de
notre amitié
est il la transforme en hostilité bail
en faisant des montagnes de tout petits
détails sans importance
autre chose chèque vous savez ils disent
tous que mombasa est une ville
dangereuse et que toute la côte en
général n'est pas sûr il dit ça
simplement parce que les gens là-bas
s'habille en bon musulman mais ça ne
fait pas d'eux des terroristes
que diriez vous aime indiens qui vivent
derrière leurs murs et leur barbelés
je voudrais leur dire simplement sortez
sortez nous sommes vos amis ce que l'on
vous dit ne sont que des mensonges
le kenya est un petit bout de paradis
un petit bout de paradis sur terre
à nairobi il y a aussi des américains
qui refusent de vivre coupés du monde
c'est dans le plus grand hôpital de la
ville que j'ai rendez vous avec le
docteur david silverstein
américain il vit au kenya depuis 24 ans
c'est l'un des directeurs de l'hôpital
il est respecté par tous ici on
l'appelle daktari ce qui veut dire
docteur dans la langue du pays
docteur que s'est il passé ici après
l'attentât de l'ambassade en 98
vous savez à l'hôpital nous étions tous
en état de choc
et même si la bombe a explosé à près de
5 km d'ici c'est bien ça
et bien tout le bâtiment a tremblé
et on a tous compris que quelque chose
d'énorme de terribles venait de se
produire
personne ne pouvait imaginer ce qui
s'était vraiment passé mais on a vite
compris lorsque des dizaines
d'ambulances sont arrivées aux urgences
ce jour là ce sont près de 800 blessés
qui affluent
l'hôpital est complètement débordé et
david lui organise les secours tant bien
que mal
à quoi pensez-vous ce jour là
vous avez peur vous saviez que c'était
un attentat
dans ces moments là ma seule
préoccupation était simplement sauver
autant de vies que possible
on n'a pas le temps de penser aux
implications politiques de ted
et puis vous savez à l'époque en 98 au
terrorisme personne n'y pensais vraiment
ce n'est que plus tard quand je me suis
retrouvé chez moi que j'ai commencé à
comprendre ce que l'avenir nous réserve
dans cet attentat il n'y a que douze
américains qui sont morts nous on a
perdu plus de 250 kényan
c'est pas juste
depuis les attentats les kenyans sont
devenus suspects aux yeux de l'amérique
le 11 septembre 2001 j'étais en route
pour new york nous avons été contraint
d'atterrir au canada
lorsque j'ai enfin passer la frontière
les douaniers m'ont traité comme une
terroriste baudet ils m'ont fait une
fouille au corps complets y était
c'était 13 mois qui était l'ami de
l'amérique qui avait sauvé des vies
américaines
j'étais vraiment en colère
david lui n'a pas de garde du corps
juste un chauffeur et pour toute mesure
de sécurité il porte sa ceinture à
l'arrière
le terrorisme il ne s'en soucie pas plus
que ça
vous voyez ces murs avec des morceaux de
verre encastré tout ça c'est nouveau
ça n'a rien à voir avec le terrorisme
c'est juste pour se protéger de la
délinquance car moi c'est ça qui me fait
vraiment pas
aujourd'hui il est commun de croiser un
ami qui a été attaqué il a subi une
expérience dangereux
[Musique]
alors pour échapper à la violence
urbaine david prend son avion privé
chaque vendredi après-midi direction sa
ferme à une centaine de kilomètres de là
en pleine savane africaine à peine
arrivée sur le tarmac de l'aéroport rob
un garde me demande d'arrêter de filmer
ils sont très paranoïaque ici quoi je
veux pas filmer
pourquoi à cause du terrorisme
donc pas le match
je suis désolé mais ce sont les
américains qui nous ont imposé ses
règles
je recommence à filmer après le
décollage
sept mille américains continuent à vivre
au kenya malgré les risques en survolant
la savane aux côtés de david je commence
à comprendre pourquoi
ouais
tu vois ici la vie est bien plus
excitante qu'aux états unis
j'ai tellement plus de liberté
avec mon avion je vais dans ma ferme
quand je veux
et puis j'ai un niveau de vie au kenya
que je ne pourrais pas avoir en amérique
à moins d'être multi millionnaire
il est bien quelque chose qui vous
manquent aux pays non
ma famille seulement c'est tout
on
ça y est
on est arrivé au paradis
sur la piste improvisée le chef
d'exploitation à temps david avec un 4 4
dix minutes plus tard nous serons sur
ses terres
la ferme de david silverstein est planté
au coeur d'une propriété de 50 hectares
un véritable havre de paix la première
ville n'est qu'à une trentaine de
kilomètres
dès mon arrivée je réalise qu ici le
terrorisme la criminalité doivent
sembler très lointain pour nous
accueillir rana commander la femme de
david
bonjour maurice tiens je te présente
diego oui moi je suis ta femme a désolé
mon amour
tu aurais dû voir l'atterrissage il y
avait tellement de vent que j'ai presque
atterri de travers c'était génial
[Musique]
d'ici on a une vue incroyable sur le lac
naivasha
mais ce que je préfère c'est le terrain
derrière la maison
c'est vraiment sauvage et c'est là bas
que je fais mes randonnées à cheval j'y
croise souvent des buffles des gazelles
et des antilopes aussi en grandissant
vous pensez qu'un jour vous vivriez dans
un endroit pareil
j'ai dû rêver
le rêver
en fin d'après-midi prana veut me faire
partager son rêve nous partons à cheval
pour un petit c'est paris l'occasion de
parler politique avec l
être américaines à l'étranger c'est une
grosse responsabilité vous savez c'est
important de faire contrepoids à la
politique américaine en ce moment elle
ici but est aussi dépourvu de toute
vision si idiote qu'il faut vraiment
offrir une alternative x et c'est ça
notre rôle
donné au reste du monde un visage humain
de l'amérique et montrer quelles sont
nos vraies valeurs voilà notre
responsabilité d'america expatriés et
cette vie d'expatrié je commence à y
prendre un goût certain c'est l'heure du
cocktail et si on ne plaisante pas avec
les traditions
jean py le jean ouais tu l'a oublié j'ai
oublié le jeans une catastrophe
j'étais proposer un team phonique et
j'ai oublié le jean lorsque j'ai
rechargé la voiture c'est génial des
amis des silverstein les ont rejoints
pour le week end tous sont amoureux de
l'afrique depuis plus de 20 ans et vous
d'embarras vous repartirez en amérique
pas volontairement c'est sûr pas de
jeans mais une vue imprenable sur le lac
naivasha même au bout du monde
l'importance des prochaines élections
présidentielles américaines est dans
tous les esprits
moi je pense que kerry et bouge
comprennent qu'il faut faire la guerre
contre les terroristes
parce que le terrorisme est un problème
majeur
ils sont partout doivent s'attaquer à
tout moment il faut les pourchasser sens
mais moi quand on lui demande pour qui
je vais voter je leur réponds que je
voterai pour kerry
dimanche matin je retrouve bill et le
directeur de general motors et sa petite
amie lui aussi tiens me montrer qu'il ne
plaisante pas avec les traditions
nous allons dans le seul endroit de
nairobi où les américains se retrouvent
pour prendre un petit déjeuner
typiquement américain mais c'est un peu
contre les recommandations de
l'ambassade américaine non de se
regrouper comme ça
tu sais j'ai appris au cours de toutes
ces années passées en tant qu'expatrié
que nous les américains nous aimons la
liberté
personne ne peut nous empêcher de faire
certaines choses on peut le demander
nous interdire ou encore nous conseiller
nous mettre en garde mais le brunch du
dimanche c'est une tradition américaine
et où que l'on soit dans le monde nous
trouverons toujours un lieu pour nous
retrouver
à nairobi cet endroit c'est le jazz
house et comme sur les autoroutes
américaines il est collé à une station
essence ici on entre comme dans un
moulin aucune sécurité aucun contrôle
en quelques minutes le restaurant et
remplis d'américains apparemment le
risque terroriste ne leur coupe pas
l'appétit
c'est un peu un morceau d'amérique ici
non oui c'est vraiment super c'est
vraiment toute la nourriture que j'aime
regarde là tu peux prendre des pancakes
avec du beurre et du sirop d'érable ou
encore avec de la banane et biennois
en fin de compte j'opterai pour un
burrito extra large avec du guacamole
et toi bildt a pris lesquelles
je les ai pris nature c'est tout
aujourd'hui les gens qui vivent autour
de moi ont un a priori négatif parce que
je suis américain
avant lorsque tu disais que tu étais
américain tu avais une véritable aura
les gens roulent et rencontrer
maintenant c'est plus à weight et
américain ok mais qu'est ce que tu
penses de ce qui se passe en irak alors
lorsqu'on me demande mon avis je répond
simplement je soutiens mon gouvernement
et ses actions et je pense que la
planète est plus en sécurité maintenant
et en général pour lorsque je dis ça la
conversation s'arrête net
alors bill tu vas voter pour qui
moi je suis républicain et je voterai
pour le président bush
à la veille des élections
présidentielles les spécialistes disent
que jamais l'amérique n'a été aussi
divisés ce voyage me le confirme ce qui
est peut-être vrai dans le tennessee il
est aussi ici à l'autre bout du monde